Bev had always loved going to the mall
when she was a child it meant spending
quality time with her mother taking in
the bustling science of the stores the
enticing smells of the food court when
she was on her best behavior she might
be rewarded with a new toy a soft
pretzel or A Fistful of quarters to
spend at the arcade when she was a
little bit older first coming into her
independent teenage Spirit the mall was
a place of Refuge of Freedom somewhere
she could spend time with her friends
away from her family's prying eyes
trying on outfits she'd never be allowed
to wear to school filling up on free
samples and imagining what it might feel
like to be grown up but as Bev had
gotten older Left Behind childish things
the mall had started to die she knew it
wasn't her fault but it was sad to watch
the source of so many simple Joys wither
away bit by bit stores closed one by one
driven out of business by the
convenience of online shopping slowly
but surely the thriving Center of her
Suburban youth hollowed out turned into
a graveyard of Commerce left behind in
the endless March towards the future the
colorful signs and advertisements for
coming attractions remained but there
were no customers the Phantom smell of
uneaten Cinnabon lingered in the air the
lights were on but no one was home and
then the lights went out too the city
didn't want to deal with the abandoned
malls upkeep but they didn't want to go
to the trouble of tearing it down either
so they just left it there there was a
running joke in town that the last
security guard to lock up the place had
left the doors wide open and just let
nature get inside and start taking its
course the mall belonged to the wild
plants and animals again a strange
artificial enclosure where raccoons
could scavenge and deer could hide from
hunters and their rifles then of course
the small town had done what small towns
do best it fired up the rumor mill where
a parent's pastor around email forwards
warning about dangerous Drifters hiding
out in the empty mall or gangs
conducting violent initiations there
teenagers stared each other to go inside
before chickening out and going home
riling each other up with Promises of
ghosts or evil storm mannequins ready to
attack children at recess or on Scout
camping trips gave each other nightmares
with stories of giant monsters hiding in
the old building waiting for lost kids
to wander inside so they could gobble
them up Bev knew none of that was true
it couldn't be but she still couldn't
shake the Curiosity she felt about the
mall that the town had left behind what
did it look like now what had the
elements the time the influence of
intruders both curious and destructive
done to the place she had never planned
to get into urban exploring but then
again she hadn't planned to move back to
her hometown after flunking out of law
school either it was strange being back
in such a familiar place that now so
different she could try to adjust could
let her life fade into a gray routine of
Diner breakfasts and drinks at the one
bar in town and endless cups of coffee
where she could find a way to lean into
the inherent strangeness of being back
home when she bumped into Daniel her
best friend from high school and he told
her all about his new slightly illegal
hobby she knew she had found the answer
he had a crew of fellow Urban explorers
a term they preferred to use instead of
trespassers a mix of friends from high
school and other exploring enthusiasts
he had met online Bev was casually
interested but not entirely sure if the
dangerous hobby was for her until Daniel
mentioned the mall like Bev he had
continued thinking about it long after
its official closing he wanted to go
inside to see what had happened to it
over the years and to see if there was a
crumb of Truth to any of the rumors
about what lurked inside Bev didn't take
that part seriously but her fascination
with the old mall was an enough to
convince her to join the crew on their
expedition inside Daniel provided her
with a list of rules turn off your
cellular data once you get there so the
police can prove your trespassing bring
water bring a flashlight and wear all
black the group agreed to meet about a
mile away from the old mall where they
would park their cars discuss their
plans and head inside Bev felt a bit
silly lying to her parents about where
she was going at her age but she didn't
want them to worry about her she told
them she was going to meet up with some
friends at a dance club just out of town
they didn't bother to ask what kind of
Club she would wear a black sweater
black pants boots and a black knit hat
too she was happy to leave without any
more scrutiny as she drove out towards
the abandoned Mall she gripped the
steering wheel with sweaty nervous hands
what was she thinking what if something
went wrong while they were in there the
old building could be full of exposed
wiring and loose beams just waiting to
fall down and Crush someone there could
be enough of rabid animals ready to
defend their territory she tried to
shake off the sense of foreboding Daniel
and his crew had done this sort of thing
dozens of times before everything would
be fine by the time she pulled up to the
meeting spot and parked her car Bev had
managed to calm herself down this would
be a fun weird night of poking around
the ruins of her childhood the remains
of a long gone piece of suburban
Americana and that was all nothing bad
would happen she introduced herself to
the rest of the group a pair of brothers
named Mark and Lewis that she recognized
from high school and a young woman named
Rachel who didn't look a day over 20.
she must have been one of Daniel's
internet buddies is this everybody
bevast Daniel nodded this is the crew
for tonight ready ready as I'll ever be
Bev Shrugged and laughed everyone else
nodded in agreement holding up their
various flashlights excited to get into
the mall and explore the place was every
bit as fascinating as bed had hoped it
would be a mixture of almost untouched
storefronts Khloe loads rotting off
their internal plastic mannequins
beneath plastic signs advertising going
out of business sales and the wild world
encroaching on what had once been a
piece of suburban retail Paradise
spiderwebs hung along the walls possums
and rats skittered along the floors
Vines crept along the remains of the
fountain at the center of the food court
that had long ago run dry Bev screamed
in shock as something ran across her
foot when she cast her flashlight Beam
at it she found that it was just a small
raccoon running from the sudden
intrusion on its home sorry I'll keep my
cool next time she laughed it off yeah
it's fine it happens to me too Daniel
reassured her you never quite get used
to roaming around these places in the
dark but look there's a lot of cool
stuff to check out he used his
flashlight to illuminate the food court
specifically the soft pretzel stand on
top of the stand leaning precariously to
one side was the enormous model of a
soft pretzel that had once attracted
hungry Shoppers looking for a snack
hungry equipped
wouldn't help herself she pulled out her
phone and snapped a picture it was
creepy and was a little sad but it
mostly was a reminder of the simple joys
of childhood when the flash went off it
illuminated the darkness behind the
stand and she caught the glow reflecting
in the eyes of the animals hiding back
there it unsettled her at first but she
reminded herself this place was theirs
now she and Daniel and everyone else
they were just visiting for the night
she checked her phone to see how the
picture came out and frowned hey Daniel
look at this she held out her phone to
show him and his eyes widened what is
that can you zoom in Bev zoomed in on
the picture and the two took a closer
look there in the background of the
picture just barely illuminated by the
phone's flash was a large silhouette
they couldn't make out any defining
features other than a large round head
and long thin noodle-like arms did this
place used to have a mascot or something
Daniel last Bev shook her head not that
I remember huh Daniel sighed weird
anyway where'd the others go he looked
around for their flashlights or any
other sign of Life guys did you get lost
his voice echoed through the wide empty
space but no one responded hello Bev
called out a chill running down her
spine only minutes ago she had heard the
others laughing and joking around as
they explored the other end of the mall
but now she couldn't hear a thing even
the chittering of the rats had gone
quiet suddenly a blood-curling scream
rang out and sent Bev's heart leaping
into her throat she and Daniel shared a
look of deep concern as they both
silently wondered if their worst fears
had come to pass had someone Fallen had
there been an accident she and Daniel
followed the sound looking for the
source are you guys okay Daniel shouted
the lack of response spoke volumes
whatever had happened the rest of the
group was in big trouble Bev quietly
kicked herself for neglecting to bring a
first aid kit finally the two reached
the other end of the mall where the
scream had sounded like it was coming
from but there was no one there only a
dark web smear along the ground it
looked incredibly fresh and it smelled
metallic violent Bev didn't have to look
more closely to tell that it was blood
whatever had happened to the other three
she wasn't sure they were going to find
them alive Daniel reached into his
jacket pocket and pulled out a small
pocket knife it's not much but just in
case he held it out in front of them as
they walked following the trail of blood
something crashed to the ground behind
them and Bev Whirled around to see a
large steel beam only feet away any
closer than they would have been crushed
her eyes started around searching for
any more potential danger and then she
saw it up in the rafters by the ceiling
was a strange figure it was unlike
anything she had ever seen it was tall
impossibly tall and Pitch Black its head
was bulbous with pair of feline ears on
top she could make out a nose a pair of
wide white eyes with big dark pupils and
it was smiling a broad Wicked smile
filled with Jagged Blood Stained teeth
its hair and looked like enormous white
gloves it was almost like she felt
ridiculous thinking this even as Terror
prickled at the back of her neck but it
looked like an old cartoon the sort of
thing her grandmother used to watch
except those always look friendly even
if they were a little unsettling this
thing it looked evil At first she
thought it was some sort of Twisted
graffiti or a statue left by Macabre
experimental artist but then it moved
the creature tilted its head to the side
its smile broadening and its pupils
dilated it was looking right at her and
it was excited Daniel Bev whispered
weakly I see it too he replied his voice
shaking we need to go we need to go now
Bev couldn't be sure what this thing
would do if it caught them but she
didn't want to wait around to find out
she grabbed Daniel's arm and yanked him
toward the exit it took him a moment to
start moving again Paralyzed by fear and
confusion at the incomprehensible sight
of the entity on the ceiling but once he
started running it seemed like he would
never stop the two raced toward the exit
arms and legs pumping as fast as they
could behind them they could hear the
creature chasing after them but they
didn't dare look back to see just before
they passed the threshold out of the
mall Bev felt Daniel's hand slip out of
hers she spun around searching for him
and watched in helpless Terror as the
long long arms of the creature looped
around his chest pulling him back away
from her and lifting him up in the air
it opened its massive mouth wide wider
wider and swallowed him whole Bev
screamed but she forced herself to keep
running to save herself from the same
fate she could feel the entity's eyes on
her back as she ran out the door but
once she escaped she knew it would not
chase her any further for some reason it
was letting her go she couldn't imagine
if it was out of some kind of Mercy but
she was grateful to escape with her life
just the same Bev stumbled into the
local police station a disheveled mess
face streaked with tears and told the
officer on duty what she had seen he
didn't believe her at first asking her
to repeat her story again and again
every time she insisted that she knew
what she encountered out there or at
least she knew that she couldn't explain
it the officer sat her in an
interrogation room alone with a cup of
coffee and asked her to wait until
someone more qualified to help her
arrived she wondered if they were going
to try and have her committed if they
had assumed she had lost her mind but
when a man in a white lab coat opened
the door and greeted her he said he
believed her he wasn't from a hospital
or affiliated with the police he was
from a special organization a foundation
dedicated to investigating The
Unexplained he was going to look into
what happened at the mall all he asked
was that she tell him in her own words
what she had seen I don't know she
sighed it looked like some kind of
messed up cartoon cat with the first
hand account of Bev and a series of
confirmed disappearances that could all
be traced to the and Maul the SCP
Foundation opened an official
investigation wanting to eliminate as
many potential complications as possible
the foundation selected only one
researcher actually entered the
abandoned building an operative with a
great deal of field work experience
named Dr Bagan though Dr baggin would
enter the building alone he would not be
without support he would be fitted with
a microphone and camera and his progress
would be monitored remotely by his
supervisor at a nearby Foundation site
if the need for backup arose they would
then be able to deploy additional
security officers to enter the mall and
extract Dr Bogan if at all possible he
would also be armed with a standard
pistol as well as a foundation-issued
flamethrower with the team selected and
the appropriate safety measures taken it
was time for Dr baggin to enter the mall
and see just what he could learn about
the entity dwelling inside if at all
possible he was to neutralize it and
bring it into containment alive so that
it could be studied closely in a
clinical environment a if live capture
was impossible he was instructed to
terminate the being and bring its body
in for a thorough autopsy with his
weapon already drawn and ready and his
eyes sharp and alert Dr baggin walked
into the empty mall he saw a lot of what
Bev and her friends had seen the old
pretzel Stan the dried up Fountain the
creepy but harmless Rose of faceless
mannequins still locked in the same pose
as they had held for a decade the
spiderwebs made him a little nervous but
that was Garden variety Arachnophobia
more than any real sense of danger I
don't know about this one honestly he
spoke into his microphone to his
supervisor on the other end so far seems
like this place is your standard
abandoned building death trap maybe our
missing persons just weren't careful or
properly trained to deal with navigating
a place like this just keep looking his
supervisor ordered look for anything
anomalous got it Dr baggin nodded he
stepped on something with a loud crunch
he looked down to see the oldest
staleless soft pretzel he had ever seen
anyone hungry he equipped turning his
camera towards the unappetizing site
don't worry I'll keep looking he carried
on walking heading past a shoe store a
music store some kind of novelty
porcelain figurine store he stopped at
the toy store when something Eerie
caught his eye you guys seeing this he
asked what is it bargain his supervisor
replied just this creepy stuffed animal
thing the cat right over there I don't
like how its eyes follow me when I walk
by I don't see a cat sure enough when Dr
boggin did a double take the strange cat
mic toy was nowhere to be seen well
there's your first anomalous activity he
joked though his heart was beginning to
pound nervously in his chest keep
looking he nodded and continued his
patrol of the area he couldn't get the
face of that thing that wasn't a toy out
of his head its eyes like the old Felix
the Cat clock his grandparents had in
their guest room bad thing had scared
the hell out of him as a kid he could
never sleep in the room with it all he
could think of outward's eyes going back
and forth back
stopped in his tracks he thought he
could hear the sound of a ticking clock
clear as day just behind him he turned
to look but there was no clock nothing
but darkness and emptiness the same as
everywhere else he felt something
suddenly tugging at his foot he looked
expecting to see an animal pulling at a
shoelace something ordinary but instead
he saw long pointed fingers curling
around his ankle he couldn't see what
the fingers belonged to couldn't see a
body but could only see a long looping
snake of a shadowy arm curling around
the corner up ahead before he could tell
his supervisor what was happening the
hand had grabbed hold of him and was
dragging him across the ground the hand
lifted them off the floor then dropped
him back down he felt the lens of his
camera break are you okay we lost
visuals no no I'm not shouted as he
looked up into the face of Pure Evil its
pupils were dark and endless its eyes
bloodshot its teeth bared do not send
back up I repeat do not send backup oh
God oh God the audio cut to static and
the signal was lost Dr baggin's body was
never found the entity referred to as
cartoon cat was given the object class
ketter regarded as highly dangerous and
nearly impossible to contain due to its
reality bending nature because it cannot
be physically contained the foundation
solution to minimize cartoon cats damage
was to block off access to the abandoned
mall all civilians were warned of a
deadly amount of radiation in the area
in order to deter them from conducting
any more urban exploration vandalism or
other visits to the location any of the
few survivors that have encountered
cartoon cat are given amnestics and
their experiences are written off as
substance related or Vivid nightmares
the empty Mall may not be the only place
cartoon cat has made its own nor is it
likely to be the only building of its
kind that houses an anomalous monster
after all when Humanity decides to
vacate a place to leave it standing
vacant and abandoned you never know what
might decide to move in now go check out
scp-096 versus siren head and scp-4158
big Charlie for more things made by the
inimitable Trevor Henderson